[Music]
oh
demands for police reform have been
front and center here in 2020
igniting protests in big cities all
across the country and here in las vegas
but leaders at metro police say they've
already embraced across the board
changes on policy
hiring and how officers interact with
the communities they serve
george knapp of our i-team looks at the
changes that have been made
[Music]
in a nondescript warehouse in east las
vegas something heavy is going down
officers cautiously move in on an armed
and troubled man
unsure how this might end elsewhere in
the same building
other officers creep toward an apartment
where an agitated resident is holed up
with a weapon
both scenarios unfold multiple times per
week
as veteran officers re-learn how to
engage
but de-escalate we're a best practice
agency
we are visited by agencies across the
nation
on how we do things sheriff joe lombardo
is proud of how far metro has come in
the last 10 years
las vegas cops have long had a
reputation of being tough customers
before this summer's demonstrations and
demands for reform
metro was ahead of the curve racial
tensions and use of force controversies
have a long history here long before the
george floyd incident
the chokehold death of las vegas charles
bush inflamed passions
in 1992 the aftermath of the rodney king
acquittals
ignited fires and violence here a decade
ago
metro had to confront the ugly numbers
showing
an inordinate number of shootings by
police many of them both black
and unarmed you know we had the doj come
in here and
evaluate us but i think the the
testament to lvmpd is yeah the doj came
in we didn't push back them coming in we
embraced them we asked them to come in
there wasn't a consent decree leveled
against us it was collaborative reform
metro instituted changes from top to
bottom in hiring
training use of force and oversight of
officers
i can pull up a dashboard of every
officer that works for me i can see how
many traffic accidents they've been in
how many use of force issues they've had
non
non-deadly and deadly how many
complaints they've had from citizens
metro's become aggressive in its
recruitment of women and minorities to
join the force
and in its community policing where
officers get to know
the neighborhoods they patrol captain
jim larochelle the policy wonk in the
sheriff's office
says metro has become a model for other
big city police departments
they're at the forefront with their
training addressing scenario based
training where you're
trying to put an officer in an
environment that mirrors the real thing
being better is not good enough as with
george floyd one
bad apple can besmirch an entire agency
metro still gets slapped with lawsuits
almost weekly
justifiably or not it probably will
always be that way
and like i've always said we hire from
the human races all the good bad and
indifferent and faults and bugs and
warts and everything that goes along
with it
and sometimes we can't weed all that out
george knapp 8 news now
while there have been calls for police
reform one major change that took place
at metro police involves banning the
controversial restraint used by some
officers
it is the lateral vascular neck
restraint the department took action in
july to limit its use
nevada legislators banned it during a
special session
the i-team's vanessa murphy takes a
broader look at the number of use of
force incidents
by metro police the department of
justice announced in 2012
the metro police department needed to
change after an extensive review the doj
wrote in this report
the shooting of unarmed suspects remains
a concern
for example between 2007 and 2011 there
were 10
officer involved shootings that involved
unarmed suspects
seven were black i think it's safe to
say they were not in keeping
with best practices the department
implemented multiple changes
in 2019 metro reports out of 16
shootings by police
15 of the subjects were armed there is
an emphasis on de-escalation techniques
in this report analyzing a five-year
period through
2019 the department provides use of
force data
while also acknowledging lessons are
still being learned
it notes four critical incidents in 2019
in which the coroner determined officers
actions
may have contributed to the subject's
cause of death
[Music]
the clark county coroner's office ruled
byron williams death a homicide because
the prone restraint
officers placed him in was a factor in
addition to meth in his system and
health issues
he ran from police after they tried
stopping him for not having a bicycle
light
once they had him in custody williams
told officers he couldn't breathe at
least
24 times multiple officers deactivated
their body cameras at the scene
he deserves justice like what they did
to him was not
was not right it was not fair it was
inhumane the use of force review board
comprised of both commissioned officers
and
three citizens determined officers
should have
immediately rolled williams on his side
after he was handcuffed
and their medical response violated
training and policy
metro took action notifying all officers
to place suspects on their side or sit
them up
so they are not kept in a position like
williams was
and to get medical attention immediately
in a situation like this
the department also updated policy
officers must
keep their body cameras on while at a
scene donovan britt is a citizen
volunteer on the review board we kind of
see these
events and we understand what they
should be doing and something that's
outside of the norm we have we can focus
in on and go why is that the case
the board also makes recommendations on
officer discipline
according to the department out of 31
cases reviewed in 2019
14 officers were disciplined none were
fired and one resigned
captain fred haas works in internal
affairs if there are bad cops out there
i don't want them standing next to me
out there in the community
and throughout the community in 2020
there were black lives matter protests
and calls for police reform while metro
is more advanced than many departments
incidents like william's death
demonstrate there are still serious
flaws
that need to be fixed vanessa murphy
8 news now there is more information for
you on police use of force hirings and
firings and diversity on the department
force
at 8newsnow.com just click on the state
of metro banner
at the top of the page next on politics
now money for education
the hurdle passed by two ballot
initiatives that would raise taxes for
our schools
this is 8 news now
the valley's biggest teachers union has
turned in two ballot initiatives for the
2021 legislative session
it would increase taxes and send that
money to education
initiatives from the clark county
education association target the gaming
tax in the sales tax
so let's explain how a statutory
initiative petition works
both received double the number of
signatures needed about a hundred
thousand
once they're certified the measures go
to the 2021 legislature
if lawmakers do not approve the new
taxes the measures then go to the voters
they would need to approve it in the
2022 general election
now let's look at the initiatives the
first initiative would raise the top
tier of the gaming tax from six point
seven five percent to nine point seven
five percent
the ccea says it would raise about 340
million dollars every year
that money would go into the state's
general fund the second is a 1.5
percentage point increase in the state's
sales tax
here in clark county would go up from
8.35 percent
to 9.875 percent the ccea estimates that
would generate a little over a billion
dollars a year
the hike would be on the portion of the
sales tax known as the local school
support tax
that makes up 2.6 percentage points of
the state's sales tax
and would go up to 4.1 percent funds
raised by that portion of the tax would
then go directly to schools
in what to watch this week we are
keeping an eye on what the governor is
going to do about the coronavirus
governor steve sisolak gave a two-week
deadline to see a drop in cases
or the state would have to add some kind
of mitigation measures
our cases have certainly gone up in that
time frame instead
the governor has not directly said what
extra measures he's considering but
two weeks runs out on tuesday we're
expecting a press conference
in the first part of the week we'll keep
an eye on what the governor says with
regards to the coronavirus and any
possible restrictions
as the week goes on thank you for
watching politics now we will see you
next week have a good rest of the
[Music]
weekend
you